Dorothea: Drawing is the bones of thought.
I always find I'm reading or seeing
or doing something and the only way
I can think is with my hands and drawing.
I went to Black Mountain College in 1950.
Two weeks after I was at Black Mountain
I must have said something
because Max came up to me and said,
"I want you to take my class."
Max Dehn was a mathematician.
While people came from all over the world
just to study with him, he never had
more than three students, but the students
he had were really significant.
When he asked me to take
his class, I was horrified.
I said, "I've had no training;
I can't take your class."
He said, "You haven't been math poisoned"
which is right.
He said, "I will teach you
mathematics for artists."
He showed me mathematics in nature.
He wasn't teaching a mathematician,
he was teaching an artist
how to think mathematically.
It was so wonderful and so heady.
I felt big! (laughs)
I was studying transitive geometry
and I wanted to find
a transitive material.
I located the carbon paper,
and by folding and unfolding
the sheets, I could
transpose the equations
I'd been working into
a materialized artwork.
I was very interested in the fact that
the whole room should represent the art.
I painted the walls with the brightest
white paint you could find.
As people walked into the room,
their footprints became
part of the drawing.
That was my plan.
I lived on Chamber Street.
I was working all kinds of jobs at once
plus I had a child I was raising,
and I didn't have the money to buy
art supplies; they were expensive.
So I went across the street
to the hardware store
and I bought crude oil,
gallons of crude oil.
People look on the crude oil as
a big insight into material.
Believe me, it was not.
It was accident. (laughs)
But I also had done some tests
and I knew what it would do
and I knew that it had
incredible properties.
Color-wise it fell right
into my Beaux-Arts training
because this was a natural,
in the earth material
and to me it has a lot of color.
By this time I'd been looking
at a lot of Italian painting
and realized that they were
all based on the golden mean.
I was very familiar with what
the golden mean looked like.
Our bodies are all golden mean.
This is all golden mean.
Everything is, you begin
to realize. (laughs)
It's a magic proportion.
If you do anything using
it, you can't go wrong.
It's bound to be a success!
It's amazing!
I wanted to work with curves
because everything that
moves in the universe
moves on an elliptical.
I was able to work with the watercolor
very, very thick, so it
has a real presence to it.
The canvas has been painted white,
so that acts like the
white surface of paper,
and it resonates through the colors.
When one is dealing
with art or mathematics,
there's always an element of magic.
If everything adds up and works out well,
you're on the wrong trail.